THE GAME IS ON.
THIS COULD WITH IT.
AHCAN GETS HIS FIRST
TOUCH.
>>Andy: GO BACK TO
THIS NICE PASS TO
BLUE
LINE.
SERGACHEV OFF OFOFTHE E
GRZELCYK CROSS ICE.
ALEX KILLORN.
STAMKOS GOOD YEAR.
COYLE.
SMITH WITH TAYLOR
RADDYSH.
CAUGHT FLAT-FOOTED.
THE CLEARING ATTEMPT
GETS
KNOCKED DOWN BY MIKE
EV
LET'S GO BACK TO THE NO
CAN
STILL SUPPORT ON GOAL.W
EVENTUALLY.  PALAHAVE H
SMITH.
CONNOR
TO JAKE DEBRUSK.
NOT QUITE.
NOSEK.K.
>>Andy: AHCAN VERY OF
VASILEVSKIY. FOR
HAULA.
PALAT FEEDING IT
ACROSS.
ALEX KILLORN CAN'T
PENALTY KILL.  HOME.
>>Andy: AGAIN, THE
BRUINS LEVSKIY.
>>Jack:
THE SECOND LAYER IS BY
STICK MOVE.
TAYLOR RADDYSH
BACK TO CHARLIE
COYLE, TAYLOR HALL
SIDE!
MIKE REILLY THE ONLY
MAN